Speaker 1: All right. Before we go to a break, we
talked this week about Glenn Beck's reactionary
fear porn as we talked about it on yesterday's
show. We also talked this week about Donald
Trump floating the idea of the death penalty for
people who he believes, I guess, committed crimes
related to spying on his campaign, which is not
at all what was claimed by the Durham report. And
this has become its own sort of echo chamber
story. Donald Trump appeared this week on the
Glenn Beck program, and on that program, again,
he talked about, you know. We used to kill the
people that did the things that Hillary's people
are accused of doing as far as he's concerned.
Let's take a look at just a little bit of this.
Speaker 2: So the biggest scandal was when
they spied on my campaign. They spied on my
campaign. There's no real evidence of that.
Was there is over the place Leslie specified in
my campaign and they gone. Can I say something?
You know, this is 60 Minutes and we can't put
on things. We can't verify it on because it's
bad for. We can't do things we can't.
Leslie, they spied on my campaign and
we can't from totally verified. No, it's
been. Just go down and get the papers.
They spoke to my camp. The papers
Speaker 1: have flushed, maybe,
Speaker 2: and they got caught. No. And then they
went much further than that and they got caught.
And you will see that, Leslie. And you
know that, but you just don't want to know.
As a matter of fact, I don't know that.
Speaker 1:
OK, so that was that was from 60
Minutes years ago, and of course,
Lesley Stahl was right. There was no
evidence of what Trump was claiming,
but now Glenn Beck is going to pretend there is.
Speaker 2: We just don't have the facts. Well,
Leslie, now you do.
Speaker 3: And President
Trump is here to discuss perhaps why CBS and
everybody else is not talking about this.
Speaker 1: Welcome to the. They're not talking
about it because Fox News and right wing media
have created a false story and there is
nothing to talk about. That's the reality
Speaker 3: program. President Donald Trump.
Speaker 4: Well, thank you, Glenn.
Great to be with you.
Speaker 3: Thank you. So
this is this is pretty amazing. You were right
when you said this is worse than Watergate.
This is far worse than Watergate. And it's not. We
don't seem to have anybody in the mainstream media
that cares about it at all.
Speaker 4:
Well, in Watergate, they broke into a department
in Watergate, and they took some things and
nothing good about it, and it turned out to be a
disaster. This is far bigger. They broke into my
campaign and all of that, but perhaps most
importantly, they they broke into the Oval
Office. They broke into the White House at the
highest levels. So illegal. And as you know,
being somebody that knows history probably better
than almost anyone else, that would have been
a short time ago. It would have been considered
treason. And I agree you know what treason is
punishable by. And a longer time ago,
it would have been punishable by death
when there it is. Again, we're in a tough country.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And I wonder if I wonder
if the bit. I wonder if there's
going to be any punishment at all
with this. I mean, Hillary Clinton.
Speaker 1: OK, so remember, the people
Trump is talking about have not been accused.
Never mind charged with any crime. And Trump is
talking about the death penalty. What happened
here is that right wing media and the Trumpian
wing of the Republican Party exploded because of
a court filing from special counsel John Durham.
What they are saying, Trump and others, is that
the there is definitive proof in the filing that
Democrats, I guess directed by Hillary Clinton,
illegally spied on Trump in 2016 and in 2017.
The truth is, the filing does not allege
espionage. It says a Clinton linked lawyer,
Clinton linked lawyer, and you have to
then actually prove whether there was
any active link between them at the time it is
associated with Hillary Clinton historically
obtained nonpublic data from the White House
and Trump's servers. Now, if it happened
as described and you can indicate that a crime
was committed, then the lawyer should be charged.
If you believe that there is an actual
operational link to Hillary Clinton,
then you should demonstrate it. And
if there's criminal liability? OK,
but so you see, we're already three or four
levels removed here, and there is no actual
evidence from the Durham report. There's almost,
first of all, nothing new in the Durham report.
It's not an indictment. It doesn't allege criminal
conduct. It basically is an issue of conflict of
interest. And what John Durham is saying is we've
discovered here a potential conflict of interest.
There's this lawyer, Sussman. He worked at the
law firm Perkins Coie. Perkins Coie represents
the DNC. Hillary Hillary's a Democrat. There is a
potential conflict of interest here. That's what
this is fundamentally about so far. And I got
a couple of emails from people in the audience
saying, David, why haven't you covered this? Fox
News is all over it. Fox News is making you think
Hillary's about to get arrested and indicted and
imprisoned. She's not. And again, Trump is talking
about the death penalty for people who have not
even been accused of a crime. We're talking about
conflict of interest at this point in time. So
that's what it is. If you want to see the clip,
Trump, Glenn Beck will have it on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.